and I said it already
the consequences for society are immense
both in cultural
socially and financially
last year left yes in the 20
by Dr Jan van De Beek
professor doctor of the week must say
what the financial
and social
costs of asylum migration for our country
between 2023 and 2027
based on the then applicable
so lower prognosis
it is 1 conservative calculation
1 pair of conclusions and facts
1 asylum seeker costs 1 treasury
although his entire life course earns on average
8t I already said that to the griffin of VAT
and that is average
there are also
people who do a lot of work and earn money
but average
if you take all together
per person 8t over the entire life course
the annual costs for asylum policy
we carry an average of 24 billion euros
only to the influx of previous
year it comes to 1 cost item of 28 billion
euro 90,000 extra social
rental properties are needed for the influx until 2027
to catch
note that is on top of the existing housing shortage
the extra costs and assistance amount to 1 billion
euros per year
and the extra costs due to increased crime
are estimated at 12 billion in the long term
euro chairman
that conclusion is clear
at unchanged
asylum policy is confronted in the Netherlands
with consequences that simply
cannot be worn by our society
this policy sets our prosperity
our social security our education
our concern our housing market at stake
and put our security and
culture under pressure
and there goes the coercive law
because that's what today is about
which only provides for processing this inflow
but not containment
do nothing about it
as my wise Father said to me this morning
the law of compulsion is when all dikes cross
to prevent sea level from rising